bien Madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues
c'est une joie de vous revoir cher
Chantal Jouanno ou plus exactement de
vous retrouver ici puisque vous avez
siéger au Sénat entre 2011 et 2017 et
que vous étiez avant votre départ membre
de notre commission et présidente de la
délégation droit des femmes
notre commission vous avez reçu en mars
2018 à l'occasion de votre nomination à
la tête de la Commission nationale du
débat public pour un mandat de 5 ans
puis en octobre 2019
il était donc temps si j'ose dire de
vous entendre à nouveau
je rappelle que la CNDP est une autorité
administrative indépendante chargée
d'organiser les débats publics sur les
projets les plans et programmes ayant un
impact majeur sur l'environnement
son rôle est de permettre au public
d'être informé le mieux possible et de
participer à la prise de décision en
plaçant son action dans le cadre des
principes d'indépendance des principes
de transparence et d'égalité de
traitement des contributeurs
votre parcours et votre expérience sont
particulièrement précieux au moment où
notre pays fait face à des choix
déterminants pour son avenir avec la
pression imposée par dérèglement
climatique et l'érosion de la
biodiversité
la concertation avec le public et la
participation des citoyens aux décisions
ayant des impacts sur l'environnement
sont essentiels pour mener à bien les
transitions qui sont devenues qui sont
devant nous car elles constituent la
garantie de l'acceptabilité de
l'effectivité de ces transitions
aussi nous souhaitions particulièrement
vous entendre dans le cadre de l'examen
un prochain par le Sénat du projet de
loi relatif à l'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelables qui a
été déposée sur le bureau de notre
assemblée le 26 septembre dernier et
donc certaines mesures du texte initial
concernent directement la CNDP je pense
notamment à l'éolien en mer toutefois de
nombreuses autres sujets sur lesquels
travaillent la CNDP intéresse notre
commission je pense au futur débat sur
le nouveau programme nucléaire français
au débat qui s'est achevé il y a peu sur
le nouveau plan de gestion
des matières et déchets radioactifs à
celui sur la politique agricole commune
ou encore à divers projets et plans
structurant pour nos territoires qui
font l'objet d'une intervention de la
CNDP
en août le Parlement devrait examiner
avant le 1er juillet 2023 une loi de
programmation relative à l'énergie et au
climat dans ce cadre et pour alimenter
les travaux préparatoires de ce texte
texte important une concertation
nationale sur le système énergétique est
en cours sous les sous l'égide de la
CNDP
conformément à la saisine du 23 février
2022 signé par la ministre de la
transition énergétique et le mini chargé
des relations avec le Parlement et de la
participation citoyenne le président de
la République en outre indiqué que cette
concertation nationale aurait lieu au
second semestre 2022 on comprend donc
déjà soit dit au passage que le
calendrier fixé par le code de l'énergie
visant une adoption de cette loi de
programmation avant le 1er juillet 2023
ce calendrier sera difficilement tenable
le gouvernement l'a d'ailleurs lui-même
déjà reconnu
je rappelle enfin que nous examinons
chaque année les crédits budgétaires qui
contribuent au fonctionnement de la CNDP
et qui sont inscrits dans le programme
2017 de la mission de 217 de la mission
écologique développement et mobilité
durable à cet égard vous nous direz si
les moyens budgétaires à louer cette
année à la commission président et vos
effectifs budgétaires vous semblent à la
hauteur des missions qui vous sont
assignées avant de vous laisser la
parole je souhaiterais vous poser deux
questions luminaires d'abord près de 5
ans après votre nomination qu'elle
regarde portez-vous sur le
fonctionnement de la démocratie
environnementale dans notre pays
et sur les évolutions législatives et
réglementaires intervenues en la matière
ces dernières années
grâce à votre expérience sur des projets
récents vos interactions avec les
ministères et des sujets sur lesquels
vous travaillez avec le nom quels
obstacles
identifiez vous renforcement de la
culture de la participation et de la
concertation dans notre pays à l'inverse
qu'elles sont pour vous les atouts de
notre modèle de démocratie
environnementale par rapport à nos
voisins européens
je serai notamment preneur de votre
retour d'expérience sur les laboration
de la loi climat et résilience que notre
commission a examiné au fond et qui
était né de l'exercice assez particulier
de la convention citoyenne dont la
méthodologie ne correspondait pas du
tout
[Musique]
et pas du pas tout à fait à celle que la
CNP a l'habitude de mettre en place
ensuite pouvez-vous nous présenter les
grandes lignes de la méthode de
concertation en cours sur leur futur loi
de programmation énergique climat la
gouvernance de la concertation et les
étapes du processus
madame la Présidente je vous laisse à
présent répondre à ces premières
questions puis nous nous concentrerons
si vous le voulez bien sur le projet de
loi relatif à l'accélération de la
production des énergies renouvelables et
je donnerai la parole à un autre
rapporteur du Diamanti qui vous
interrogera spécifiquement sur ce texte
ainsi qu'à l'ensemble de nos collègues
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs je
suis ravie de vous retrouver surtout en
cette salle que je sais que vous avez dû
quitter quelques temps en raison du
contexte sanitaire alors juste peut-être
effectivement pour répondre à vos
questions
présentées en une minute la Commission
nationale du débat public et une
institution qui a 25 ans qui a été
transformé en autorité administrative
indépendante assez rapidement d'ailleurs
puisque son rôle est de garantir un
droit qui est inscrit dans la
Constitution qui elle-même en fait
reprend d'ailleurs des enseignements de
la convention internationale d'arus qui
est le droit de l'information et à la
participation du public à l'élaboration
des décisions sur les projets qui en
impact sur l'environnement et chaque mot
compte c'est bien un droit à
l'information donc nous devons veiller à
ce que le public a accès à une
information pluraliste contradictoire et
surtout compréhensible
et lisible par lui donc nous n'aimons
pas cette information nous n'avons pas
le droit de le faire mais nous veillons
au contraire à ce que est l'information
qui émane du maître d'ouvrage et celle
qui est mal d'autres acteurs soit la
plus accessible possible quant au droit
à la participation c'est pas simplement
un droit à être consulté c'est vraiment
participé à l'élaboration des décisions
et ceci se traduit de manière concrète
par le fait qu'à l'issue d'un débat
public ou d'une concertation le maître
d'ouvrage donc celui qui a eu
l'obligation de nous saisir en général à
l'obligation de dire ce qu'il retient ou
pas du débat public et quand ils ne
retient pas des propositions qui émanent
du public pourquoi il ne les retient pas
donc il a l'obligation de motiver
sa décision
autre point important c'est qu'en fait
on n'a pas du tout le même rôle que les
commissions enquêteurs les commissaires
enquêteurs interviennent à la fin de
l'élaboration du projet juste avant
l'autorisation d'engager les travaux
pour émettre un avis sur le projet
favorable ou défavorable nous nous
intervenons au tout début de
l'élaboration du projet à un moment où
on peut débattre de son opportunité même
est-ce qu'il faut faire ou pas ce projet
ce qui est l'essence même en fait du
débat public et on a une obligation
absolue de neutralité c'est à dire que
nous ne devons jamais émettre d'avis sur
le fond du projet on ne peut émettre
d'avis que sur la qualité de la
participation voilà notre activité est
la fortement augmentée depuis 5-6 ans
puisque elle a été multipliée par 7 on a
entre 130 et 150 procédures par an de
concertation ou de débat public sur des
sujets effectivement très très variés
voilà quelques mots d'abord de
présentation de notre de notre
fonctionnement
la démocratie environnementale en France
est très particulière on a effectivement
depuis 25 ans une loi qui est très
élaborée qui est plutôt d'ailleurs
reconnu on reçoit très souvent des
délégations internationales qui
s'inspirent du modèle français l'Italie
vient d'adopter une une loi qui crée
l'équivalent de la CNDP en Italie avec
cette idée donc pour les grands projets
c'est important de pouvoir débattre de
leur opportunité très tôt avant
d'engager des études et des frais très
importants pour les pour les mettre
d'ouvrage donc cette démocratie elle
fonctionne bien comme je vous le disais
on a quand même une très forte
augmentation des des procédures on nous
sollicite énormément pour des missions
de conseils notamment des collectivités
nous sollicitent pour des missions de
conseil et pour présider chaque année
les Trophées de la participation je peux
aussi témoigner que les petites communes
ont une activité participative
extrêmement importante cette année les
dossiers les plus nombreux émanent de
communes de moins de 10 000 habitants
donc la démocratie fondamental va plutôt
bien ceci dit concernant les récentes
dispositions qui ont été adoptées c'est
vrai que alors qu'on a toujours connu un
mouvement de progression du droit à la
participation on a connu quelques
régressions assez importantes la
première et le fait que avait été créé
un droit pour que sur des projets qui ne
sont pas obligatoirement soumis à la
CNDP le public les associations ou les
collectivités pendant un délai de quatre
mois bénéficie d'un droit d'initiative
qui était le droit de saisir la CNDP sur
sur ces projets ce délai a été raccourci
à deux mois par la loi ASAP ensuite à
l'issue de la loi ASAP un décret a été
adopté et d'ailleurs il a été signé le
30 juillet de mémoire a été adopté qui
multiplie par deux les seuils au-delà
desquels la saisine de la CNP est
obligatoire donc en d'autres termes il y
a environ 45% des projets qui étaient
auparavant obligatoirement soumis à la
CNDP pour participation qui ne le sont
plus ils ne peuvent pas être
nécessairement rattrapés par une
procédure volontaire à l'initiative des
citoyens ou des associations puisque
comme je viens de vous l'expliquer le
délai du droit d'initiative lui a été
divisé par deux or c'est assez compliqué
pour des associations de connaître
l'existence d'un projet et de
s'organiser pour exercer ce droit ce
droit d'initiative autre point dans le
cadre de la loi énergie climat il a été
décidé que la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie qui
auparavant était soumise à débat public
potentiellement ne le serait plus et
qu'elle ferait l'objet d'une
concertation dont les conditions restent
à définir par un décret dont on n'a pas
connaissance
à ce jour donc plusieurs évolutions
législatives effectivement ou
réglementaire qui ont restreint le champ
de la participation en tout cas
concernant la CNDP et en parallèle quand
même effectivement pas mal d'initiatives
dans dans ce domaine donc vous avez cité
la convention citoyenne
la convention citoyenne sur le sur le
climat en soi les exercices alors nous
on les appelle de mini public c'est
parce que c'est les publics tirés au
sort mais il y a différentes modalités
de tirage au sort ce sont pas des
exercices nouveaux c'est des exercices
qui ont été pratiqués de longue date je
crois qu'on l'a utilisé en 2004 la
première fois
pardon je manque à tous mes devoirs mais
vraiment j'ai honte je suis accompagnée
de des vice-présidentes et
vice-présidents de la CNDP Ilaria Casio
et Florent gagneur qui vont
notamment pouvoir vous expliquer comment
va se passer la concertation nationale
même si on n'a pas encore les dates donc
pardon
cette convention donc elle n'est pas
nouvelle dans ses modalités puisque ce
sont des exercices qui ont déjà été
pratiqués de longue date on en a fait
une trentaine en fait dans le cadre de
débat public par exemple pour la PPE on
avait réuni 400 citoyens tirés au sort
qui avait été réuni à l'Assemblée
nationale pour effectivement
hiérarchiser différentes propositions
donc on n'est pas tout ça pour dire que
les conventions citoyennes on y croit
puisqu'on les utilise nous-mêmes ceci
dit deux éléments le premier c'est que
on ne peut pas uniquement reposer sur
des conventions citoyennes pour
organiser la participation du public il
est important que toutes les personnes
potentiellement concernées par un sujet
puisse bénéficier de la même information
et puisse participer
au débat public donc cet exercice doit
toujours être complété par un exercice
ouvert au grand public que ce soit sous
différentes modalités mais en tout cas
dans notre jargon on dit qu'il faut
toujours mélanger mini public et maxi
public le deuxième élément et ce qui
était le plus délicat et ce qui est le
plus important quand on fait de la
participation c'est pourquoi on le fait
la participation se justifie pas en
elle-même le pourquoi on le fait c'est
quel lien on
garantit à la décision qu'est-ce que le
décideur s'engage à mettre en débat et
surtout comment ils s'engagent à le
reprendre ou pas et c'est effectivement
ce qui a posé problème dans la mesure où
sur cet exercice il y avait aucune
garantie légale sur la manière dont les
conclusions de la convention seraient
reprise ensuite par par les décideurs au
sens le plus
le plus large le s'agissant de la
concertation énergique climat peut-être
que je vais tout de suite laisser la
parole à Ilaria et Florent puisque on
avait pourquoi cette concertation
énergique climat on travaille avec EDF
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois sur la
saisine qui nous ont adressé concernant
les projets de construction de nouveaux
EPR
et donc il va y avoir un débat public
qui va
être organisé à partir du 27 octobre
donc il sera ouvert le 27 octobre
jusqu'au 27 février sur l'ensemble du
programme de construction de nouveaux
réacteurs dont principalement les deux
réacteurs EPR 2 à penlis et nous avions
signalé au gouvernement par un avis que
préalablement il aurait été opportun
quand même de pouvoir mettre en débat la
place de l'énergie nucléaire dans
l'ensemble du mix énergétique et de
mettre en ébat donc l'ensemble du mix
énergétique ce à quoi le gouvernement a
répondu favorablement donc il arrive
Florent ont mené une mission de conseil
pour proposer la méthode de concertation
qui sera sous l'égide du gouvernement
celle-ci c'est pas la CNDP qui qui
l'organise
la méthode a été proposée donc en avril
et on attendait impatiemment que la
concertation nationale puisse s'ouvrir
puisque cet exercice comme le débat
public sur les EPR à vocation à éclairer
le Parlement à être versé en fait au
débat au Parlement qui auront lieu sur
la future loi de programmation énergie
climat donc c'est important que les
conclusions de cet exercice
interviennent avant les débats les
débats parlementaires et c'est vrai
qu'on aurait préféré que la concertation
nationale interviennent avant le débat
sur
les EPR ce qui apparemment n'a pas été
possible côté gouvernement puisque il
n'était pas prêt mais il a rien
peut-être que je te laisse présenter la
si tu Jean-François
les éléments de cette concertation
bonjour donc comme la présidente le
disait nous avons proposé au
gouvernement un rapport dans lequel nous
avons détaillé la méthode pour mettre en
place cette concertation nationale sur
le système énergétique de demain au cœur
de cette méthode il y avait les liens
très étroits entre démocratie
participative et démocratie
représentative c'est-à-dire le fait que
cette concertation devait se rattacher
au débat parlementaire qui est souverain
dans le domaine de
dans le cas qui nous occupe dans le
domaine de l'énergie et donc nous avons
proposé une méthode qui mettait un
dialogue c'est de forme de démocratie ce
qu'on fait souvent à la cnvp parce que
nous considérons qu'il est très
important d'articuler c'est de forme de
démocratie qu'il y en a une qui était
très à apprendre des décisions c'est la
démocratie bien évidemment
représentative donc c'est pourquoi nous
avons proposé au gouvernement ont tout
d'abord un certain nombre de thèmes de
sujets trois en particulier le sujet de
la consommation vous voulez se prêter
mais pas seulement le sujet de la
production donc énergétique Linux
électrique et le sujet de la gouvernance
et des coûts donc trois grands sujets
autour de quel la concertation devait
s'articuler avec deux grands volets
envolés maxi public c'est-à-dire
vraiment un tour de France des
territoires notamment des régions parce
qu'elle a la question énergétique ne se
décline pas que ce soit en termes de
consommation de production pareil dans
toutes les régions françaises et une un
moment un peu plus délibératif avec ce
qu'on nous avons appelé un forum des
jeunesse avec environ de ce de son jeune
tirés au sort âgé de 18 à 35 ans pour
travailler vraiment sur dévoler
particulier de l'alpec la loi énergie et
climat tout ça pour nourrir non
seulement le projet de la gouvernement
mais d'abord et surtout le débat
parlementaire et c'était très important
que ça vienne en amont parce que comme
je le disais tout à l'heure c'est les
parlementaires qui vont pouvoir et
devoir se positionner et voter donc ils
seront éclairés de tout un tas
d'éléments parmi lesquels là on va dire
l'expertise citoyenne ou là où la voix
des de celles et ceux qui auront
participé ça nous paraît un élément
d'éclairage essentiel pour le vote et ce
qui est important aussi c'est que la
première ministre vient de nous
missionner comme garant de la
concertation donc nous n'avons pas
seulement élaboré la méthode de cette
concertation nous allons aussi la
garantir au sens que nous verrons à la
transparence la transparence de la
méthode et la manière dont elle va se
mettre en place la manière dont les
réunions vont se passer et aussi la
manière dont ce forum des jeunesse va se
mettre en place une autre élément de
cette garantie c'est le fait que c'est
nous qui allons restituer ce qui se
disent qu'il y a un élément très
important la démocratie participative et
en fait quoi le fait d'inviter nos
concitoyens s'exprimer donc on manie la
parole de celles et ceux qui s'expriment
cette donnée qui ont donné qualitative
elle a quand même difficile à manier
dans le sens où elle peut être des forts
orientaux orientés donc elle nécessite
d'un traitement neutre transparent et
exhaustif donc c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement a considéré opportun de
nous confier aussi cette tâche de
rédiger le compte-rendu de le tour de
France des régions mais aussi de travail
des forums des jeunesse et dans la
lettre des missions de la première
ministre et les précisé aussi que c'est
notre rapport qui devrait éclairer les
travaux de l'axe transmission
énergétique de CNR qui a été mis en
place par le gouvernement donc un rôle
important qui a été donné à la garantie
de la CNP dans cette mission voilà
merci je lui ai donné la parole à notre
rapporteur Didier modélie je tiens à
saluer la présence de Patrick Chauvet
qui devra nous quitter parce qu'il est
une matinée un peu chargée qui est le
rapporteur désigné par la commission des
affaires économiques sur les articles
que nous avons délégué au fond
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente je souhaite vous interroger
sur le texte relatif comme le président
évoqué avec ces ration de la production
d'énergie renouvelable nous examinerons
mercredi prochain dans cette même salle
en commission sur ce texte mais qui
contient un terme de sujets mais
d'autres nifs pas alors qu'ils sont
essentielles pour garantir et
acceptabilité la rapidité certains
parlent de la procréation d'ailleurs du
développement des énergies renouvelables
donc nous avons besoin à la fois pour
garantir la sécurité d'approvisionnement
en électricité nous adapter aux
dérèglement climatique et à ses
conséquences question très générale tout
d'abord est-ce que vous avez relevé des
points forts et des points faibles dans
dans ce texte ensuite je souhaiterais
vous interroger plus précisément sur
l'enjeu de la planification la terre et
en mer et la concertation avec le public
pour la planification terrestre du
développement des énergies renouvelables
quelle méthode nationale ou territoriale
et où Theresa elle recommandez-vous à
quelle échelle cette planification ou de
planification pourrait-on identifier les
zones qui pourraient accueillir les
projets d'énergie renouvelable que ce
soit du solaire l'éolien méthanisation
etc sous quelle forme pour être associé
le public à la définition de ces zones
qu'elle devrait être la place des élus
selon vous dans la prise de décision
relative à l'identification de ces zones
puis dans l'implantation des projets sur
le terrain s'agissant des projets
éoliens en mer la Commission nationale
du débat public était saisie à de
multiples reprises afin d'organiser la
participation du public sur des projets
faisant l'objet d'appel d'offres dès
2013 avec le parc de Saint-Nazaire qu'on
a ouvert récemment et pour les parcs du
Sud Bretagne et de centre manche dans la
perspective de l'examen du projet de loi
pourriez-vous nous faire part des
principaux enseignements à tirer des
consultations organisées sur les projets
au lieu en mer
identifiez-vous des écueils contenus de
cette expérience récente à corriger
j'aimerais en particulier savoir si vous
avez identifié des pistes
pour renforcer l'acceptabilité des
projets dès le stade de la concertation
préalable par exemple à travers un
renforcement de l'information mise à
disposition du public sur les enjeux que
découvre les zones d'implantation
envisagées en matière de préservation de
la biodiversité et plus largement de
conciliation des différents usages de la
merde selon vous cette information
est-elle suffisante aujourd'hui pour que
le public se prononce en connaissance de
cause sur l'implantation des parcs en
fin de la vie de certains acteurs l'une
des clés du succès du nombre de nos
voisins en matière d'éolien en mer je
pense notamment à l'Allemagne la
Belgique le Danemark réside dans
l'élaboration précoce et précise d'une
planification spatiale voire temporelle
des projets qui permettent de donner de
la visibilité aux acteurs et de
désamorcer en amont les conflits
identifiez-vous des exemples donc à
l'étranger dont nous pourrions nous
inspirer si nous devions
améliorer l'existant dans notre pays
comment selon vous la planification des
projets éoliens en mer pourrait-elle
s'organiser je vous cache pas que nous
avons quelques idées évidemment
d'ores et déjà mais c'est important de
recueillir votre avis et vos réponses à
toutes ces questions
merci Monsieur rapporteur madame la
Présidente je vous laisse répondre au
rapport merci monsieur le rapporteur
alors je ne répondrais pas la première
question point fort et point faible j'ai
pas le droit en fait puisque j'ai une
obligation de de neutralité je ne peux
me prononcer que sur les aspects qui
concernent l'information et la
participation du
du public alors si je vais commencer par
la planification très Thérèse mais assez
rapidement parce qu'en fait on a très
très peu d'eau de projets
d'énergie renouvelable terrestre dans la
mesure où généralement ils sont c'est
des petits projets nous on est
obligatoirement saisi au-dessus de 300
millions d'euros donc c'est rare que les
projets dépassent ce seuil on a eu trois
projets de parc éolien dont on court et
puis surtout le débat important sur le
projet horizéo de création d'un parc
solaire 1000 hectares en nouvelle en
nouvelle-aquitaine et c'est de ce débat
public qu'on peut tirer un certain
nombre d'enseignements
d'une part sur comment planifier et à
quelle échelle ce débat était
extrêmement intéressant puisque le
porteur de projet proposé en fait de
défricher 1000 hectares pour y installer
des panneaux solaires et les opposants
ont dit mais non puisqu'on voit bien que
dans le cadre du stradette il est
possible d'atteindre la même puissance
en posant des panneaux solaires sur les
friches donc on a on aurait largement le
potentiel donc une expertise a été
diligente il s'est avéré que les
chiffres du stradec étaient surestimé
puisqu'on souvent c'était des petits
bouts de friche et que du coup c'était
pas possible vraiment de d'optimiser des
installations sur sur ces espaces d'où
si on fait une bonne planification
terrestre la nécessité de partir du
terrain la nécessité effectivement de
pouvoir déjà très concrètement
identifier zone par zone quel usage à
quel endroit parce qu'il y a des
conflits d'usage entre des usages
agricoles des usages économiques et
l'implantation d'énergie renouvelable
donc avoir une vision beaucoup plus
précise d'avoir une vision beaucoup plus
précise aussi de où on peut les
raccorder puisque la question du
raccordement est vraiment pas neutre
donc la bonne échelle territoriale c'est
quand même l'échelle qui est la plus
proche du terrain et si on doit
envisager une planification
de notre expérience on l'avait plutôt
ascendante que descendante on verrait
plutôt une échelle qui repose déjà sur
la vision des élus locaux et des
intercommunalités sur la réalité de leur
terrain qui permettent ensuite de dire
de manière assez précise voilà
potentiellement où on pourrait installer
ce type
ce type d'énergie et ensuite de pouvoir
concilier effectivement le potentiel
avec les objectifs nationaux mais donc
plutôt une démarche ascendante puisqu'on
voit bien que quand on est à une échelle
trop large on n'a pas une connaissance
suffisamment fine du territoire pour
pouvoir
identifier ce potentiel et en plus plus
on est proche du territoire plus c'est
facile d'organiser l'information et la
participation du public puisque en fait
le public il a ce qu'on appelle une
expertise d'usage une expertise du
quotidien et il est capable de dire moi
de mon expérience voici ce qui se passe
sur le
sur le sur le terrain donc la place des
élus c'est bien d'arbitrer
d'arbitrer c'est différentes visions des
conflits d'usage potentiel des
potentiels zones d'implantation des
énergies des énergies renouvelables donc
et ça c'est aussi intéressant
on l'a vu dans je l'ai vu dans les
Trophées des participations il y a
beaucoup de démarches de terrain qui
fonctionne bien si on part au plus
proche du au plus proche du terrain et
l'éolien en mer finalement
ne dérochent pas tellement à ce que je
viens de vous dire même si
l'échelle de la mer est une échelle
beaucoup plus large et les projets dont
on parle maintenant sont vraiment des
projets industriels qui
dont on imagine encore assez peu
l'ampleur c'est à dire que je prends
l'exemple du dernier projet de parc
éolien qui est celui de centre manche à
au 5 à 8 appels d'offres 5 appels
d'offres 8 au total on est sur grosso
modo 470 et 480 km² avec des éoliennes
qui font plus de 300 mètres de haut qui
doivent être séparés d'un kilomètre pour
qu'il n'y ait pas d'effet de
perturbation entre les unes et les
autres donc on est vraiment sur des
systèmes c'est 2,5 gigawatts le
potentiel du parc donc on est sur des
des échelles industrielles monumentales
ce que nous ont enseigné les 17 débats
publics et concertations qu'on a pu
faire sur des projets de parc éolien en
mer parce qu'on en a fait 17 au total et
ce qui est extrêmement intéressant c'est
je vais simplifier je vais pas tout tout
reprendre les arguments beaucoup évolués
parce que auparavant il y avait des
arguments d'opposition économique sur le
thème c'est pas rentable or aujourd'hui
les projets de parc éolien en mer sont
effectivement rentables donc ces
arguments là on les trouve plus de même
que les arguments des climatosceptiques
deviennent très très rares dans les
débats publics par contre effectivement
ce qui demeure c'est la question du
conflit d'usage ça c'est sûr la mer est
vide et la vision qu'on a de la mère
d'un espace vide et souvent et est une
vision fausse il y a déjà des conflits
d'usage avec la pêche avec la co-culture
avec le transport avec le tourisme avec
la défense donc déjà quand on fait une
carte des zonage de la mer mais je vous
en montrerai j'en ai apporté on voit
bien que c'est quand même un espace qui
est très très dense donc il y a déjà des
conflits il y a déjà des conflits
d'usage qui qui existent l'autre
problème que l'on a en fait quand on
fait des des débats publics c'est qu'on
a très peu d'informations sur deux
sujets les questions environnementales
on connaît très très peu et les fonds
marins et l'impact sur la vie phone de
ces de ces projets de parc les fonds
marins je vais vous citer juste un
exemple intéressant sur le projet de
parc éolien sud Bretagne
à l'ouverture du débat public je
rencontre le président du comité
régional des pêches qui est depuis
président du comité national et qui me
sort une grande grande carte faite à la
main il me dit bah là tu vois ça c'est
moi qui l'ai fait à la main et ça les
tailles de la page je connais mieux les
fonds marins que l'État et c'était vrai
même l'État le reconnaît donc une
insuffisance de connaissance de donner
envie de m'en rendre mental qui fait que
d'ailleurs quand on met en débat le
public nous dit
l'environnement c'est le parent pauvre
puisque finalement on est un peu aveugle
sur cette question donc quand on débat
on n'est pas vraiment capable de
débattre des impacts des impacts
environnementaux donc ça c'est la
première donnée qui manque le
gouvernement a lancé un migraillon donc
des recherches il a mis 3 millions
d'euros sur le sujet c'est déjà bien
mais on voit bien qu'on manque encore de
on manque encore de données sur ce sur
ce point et le deuxième élément quand on
propose au public enfin quand on met en
débat des projets de parc le public nous
dit moi j'aime bien prononcer sur
celui-ci mais c'est quoi le coup d'après
c'est notamment ce qui nous avait été
dit en Normandie en 2019
c'est quoi le coup d'après donc la
question de la planification elle
devient centrale pour le débat public et
c'est pour ça qu'on avait préconisé dès
2019 que on donne de la visibilité au
public sur le nombre de parcs qui
étaient envisagés sur une sur une zone
c'est important pour le public c'est
important pour les porteurs de projets
aussi c'est important pour connaître les
impacts cumulés qui sont les impacts
environnementaux mais même sur le
fonctionnement des parcs eux-mêmes on
n'est pas on connaît pas exactement les
impacts cumulés du fonctionnement des
différents des différents parcs donc on
avait plaidé sur cette pour cette
planification et honnêtement on est très
contents que le gouvernement aujourd'hui
envisage cette planification maintenant
par rapport donc au projet de loi qui
qui vous occupent l'article 12 puisque
là c'est l'article 12 dont on parle
c'est le concrètement comment on va
faire qui me pose question et je vais
essayer de le dérouler de la manière la
plus simple
donc dans l'article 12 qui est proposé
c'est que la procédure de participation
du public sur la construction et
l'exploitation des parquets au lien en
mer pour pour simplifier soit mener en
commun avec celle effectuées sur les
documents stratégiques de façade donc on
est une seule et même procédure pour
parler et des documents stratégiques de
façade et des projets de parc de parc
éolien c'est bien sur le papier mais
concrètement ça va pas fonctionner je
vais vous et juste essayer de détailler
le pourquoi donc la planification je
vous disais elle est vraiment nécessaire
les outils actuels que ce soit la PPE la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
ou les DSF ne sont pas des outils de
planification la PPE je vous ai apporté
un exemple de la PPE qui a été adopté
pour 2019-2028 elle nous dit simplement
qu'après 2024 on aura 1000 mégawatts par
an posé ou flottant en mer elle dit
absolument pas où est de dis pas combien
potentiellement de parcs ça représente
donc c'est un objectif en terme de de
même mégawatt mais qui est très très peu
précis là les DSF les documents
stratégiques de façade comme vous savez
ils doivent
élaborer des cartes de vocation
c'est-à-dire
identifier en mer les différentes zones
et où est-ce qu'on potentiellement on
pourrait effectivement avoir des
activités économiques des activités
d'énergie renouvelables ou des activités
de transport quand vous regardez dans le
détail ces cartes de vocation
il y en a certaines qui sont très
précises d'autres pas du tout je vous ai
apporté deux exemples si vous voulez les
regarder enfin je sais pas si tu
trouvais que c'était bien d'être concret
il y a l'exemple de la carte de focation
de la façade maritime manche est mer du
Nord voilà vous avez quelques grands
rectangles où on dit bah là
effectivement prédominance de la
navigation maritime et sécurité maritime
mais zone à four potentiel de
développement et aux liens mais c'est
tout ce qui est écrit il y a pas de
zonage très très précis à l'inverse
vous prenez le DSF donc Méditerranée là
il est extrêmement détaillé et vous avez
par exemple le littoral l'angle dossier
ouest ou vous avez très précisément les
différentes zones donc celui-ci il se
serait utile si on veut faire du débat
public celui-ci il est propre il est
précis on sait vraiment où sont les
conflits les conflits d'usage il est
très il est très clairement zoné donc le
problème des DSF aujourd'hui c'est que
tel qu'ils sont on peut pas s'appuyer
partout sur les cartes de vocation pour
dire voilà potentiellement ou demain on
pourrait faire des des parcs éoliens en
mer je rappelle par ailleurs que les DSF
effectivement ils font déjà l'objet
d'une procédure de participation du
public c'est à l'échelle de la façade
on s'est donné du mal mais je dois
reconnaître qu'on n'a pas rassemblé
énormément de personnes pour participer
à ce type à ce type d'exercice et il est
évident que demain
forcément les parties prenantes vont
pouvoir seront plus actifs dans la
participation mais ça va être difficile
de mobiliser le le grand public donc
voilà s'agissant des de la difficulté en
partant de l'existence outre élément
pour élaborer les DSF il a fallu
quasiment trois ans ça s'élabore en
quatre étapes
une première étape qui concerne
l'existant ensuite les objectifs après
les modalités d'évaluation et enfin les
plans d'action les cartes de vocation
les voix au moment des plans d'action la
participation du public elle intervient
au tout début donc on est sur un
exercice qui est quand même assez
compliqué qui est très très qui est très
très long et si et si demain on voulait
mixer les deux exercices qu'est-ce qui
se passerait très concrètement
soit on part des cartes de vocation
telles qu'elles sont extrêmement
vague et on essaye d'y caser des projets
de parc éolien en mer et là évidemment
les acteurs de la mer vont nous dire
mais nous on n'a pas été concerté moi
pour la coaculture moi pour la pêche moi
pour les transports je suis pas d'accord
avec ce qui est proposé puisque on n'a
pas réglé la question des conflits
d'usage sur mer
soit effectivement on se dit bon bah on
va mettre en débat les cartes de
vocation vraiment pour régler ses
conflits d'usage et en même temps les
projets de parc éolien en mer donc on va
adopter des cartes de vocation
pour une échelle de temps les DSF c'est
6 ans pour une échelle de temps de 6 ans
et potentiellement dans 6 ans voire dans
12 ans si le DSF est renouvelé vous
allez avoir des parcs éoliens qui vont
émerger de la mer sortir de mer qui vont
sortir de mer et le public ou les élus
locaux qui vont dire mais on n'était pas
au courant on n'a pas été informé on n'a
pas été concerté sur ces projets de parc
donc on voit nous assez difficilement
comment on pourrait pas avoir d'abord
une première étape où on se met d'accord
sur les cartes de vocation sur les
conflits d'usage et il y a un arbitrage
politique parce qu'il faut un arbitrage
politique parce qu'il y a des moments où
il faut aussi voir par exemple avec la
défense si ces zones de vocation ces
zones réservées peuvent pas être un peu
modifiées ça c'est arrivé par exemple en
Normandie donc il y a des arbitrages
nécessaires dans une première étape et
ensuite dans une deuxième étape là on
met en débat effectivement les projets
de parc éolien en mer et là ce qu'on
propose c'est que plutôt que de mettre
en débat des projets un par un
pourquoi est-ce qu'on met pas en débat 5
6 voire dix projets en même temps on
aurait pu le faire en Méditerranée en
Méditerranée on a une carte de vocation
qui est suffisamment précise pour que la
limite le gouvernement nous saisisse en
nous disant bah là dans cette carte
d'évocation imaginons 10 parcs sur qu'on
va construire sur les 10 15 prochaines
années imaginons 10 parcs et on met en
débat 10 parcs ça c'est une possibilité
qui ferait vraiment gagner du temps à
tout le monde mais surtout qu'il
donnerait de la visibilité à l'ensemble
des acteurs que ce soit les acteurs
locaux ou les acteurs les acteurs
industriels maintenant ça a un
présupposé important c'est que l'état de
son côté et les moyens de le faire il
faut que en particulier la direction
générale énergie climat et les moyens
humains de le faire et de porter
l'ensemble de ces projets et c'est
peut-être là où on a une difficulté
aujourd'hui parce que la DGEC n'est sans
doute pas assez armée on l'a déjà dit
d'ailleurs en conclusion notre débat
c'est pas notre rôle mais on l'a dit
quand même en conclus du dernier débat
qu'on a fait sur Oléron qu'il fallait
augmenter les moyens humains de la DGEC
voilà en quelques mots monsieur le
rapporteur mais je peux vous faire
passer les cartes si vous voulez
oui on les mettra dans les cartes je
vais donner la parole à Monsieur
[Musique]
le Président Madame présidente dans le
contexte des crises climatiques et
énergétiques actuelles le projet de loi
dont nous discutons aujourd'hui a pour
ambition de favoriser le développement
des énergies renouvelables le Conseil
d'État a approuvé ce texte tout en
relevant que son étude d'impact était je
le cite inégal insuffisante sur
plusieurs articles voire inexistants sur
certaines dispositions pourtant
importantes
ces manques découleraient notamment des
brèves délais même des très brefs délais
dit-il dans lesquels les organismes ont
été consultés et c'est sur cette lacune
relevée par le Conseil d'État que je
souhaiterais vous interroger car vous
l'imaginez bien l'impact de ce texte
peut-être extrêmement important et
conséquent pour nos concitoyens
il prévoit notamment d'alléger les
exigences environnementales imposées
pour installer éoliennes et panneaux en
nombre et de dédommager certains
riverains s'ils acceptent près de chez
eux ces sources d'énergie verte
j'insiste depuis des années à
l'Assemblée nationale ou dorénavant au
Sénat sur les conséquences que peuvent
avoir l'installation de masse éolien
dans un territoire et je pense
spécifiquement à ma région les hauts de
France première région en termes de
nombre de mains avec 30% de la
production industrielle installée j'en
viens donc à mes deux questions
et qui rejoignent d'ailleurs les
questions qu'à poser le rapporteur
mandeli sur un sujet polémique comme
celui des éoliennes ne pensez-vous pas
que la vie des populations ou un minima
des élus locaux devraient être mieux
prises en compte jusqu'à pourquoi pas
leur donner un droit d'opposabilité
deuxième question
les délais de consultation et là je fais
toujours référence à l'analyse du
Conseil d'État les délais de
consultation pour
vous apparaît-il comme suffisant pour
que pédagogie concertation et le cas
échéant acceptation puisse rimer avec
sérieux et sérénité
merci je vais donner la parole je vais
donner la parole à trois autres de mes
collègues monsieur Houlgate
puis après tu réponds merci merci
monsieur le président madame la
Présidente je voudrais revenir un peu
sur sur l'éolien en mer pour apporter
gérer un complément d'ailleurs je vous
remercie d'ailleurs pour votre avis
puisque dans votre avis écrivez vous
avez parfaitement
mentionné le fait que il faut procéder
donc en deux temps donc à la fois au
niveau du DSF sur les objectifs généraux
et puis également mutuelle et mutualiser
les débats je voudrais simplement
peut-être noter une chose c'est que dans
la première version de l'étude d'impact
qui nous a été transmise sur l'article
12 le rédacteur de cette étude d'impact
mentionné le fait suivant en disant que
le point faible et le risque que le
volet au lieu en mer prédomine
monopolyse le débat public sur le DSF au
détriment des autres volets du DSF et et
cette phrase a disparu
parce qu'elle était sans doute gênantes
entre les deux versions de de l'étude
d'impact je voudrais vous remercier
justement parce que moi j'ai participé
donc au débat public sur la 8 et le fait
à converger sur ce qu'on appelle une
zone de moindre contrainte moi me paraît
tout à fait tout à fait prometteur ma
question va poser tout simplement sur
sur le fait que tout le monde s'accorde
à dire que la meilleure façon
d'accélérer les projets notamment c'est
d'engager le plus en amont possible
la concertation et que cette
concertation puisse s'opérer tout au
long du déroulement du projet c'est le
sens d'ailleurs de la vie du Conseil
économique social et environnemental qui
nous a je dirais fourni un rapport sur
l'acceptabilité des nouvelles
infrastructures de transition
énergétique avec transition subie
transition choisie mais aussi c'est je
dirais le travail remarquable du CGEDD
d'Ilia d'il y a un an qui propose une
refonte complète de l'ensemble des
procédures et au titre de cette fonte il
propose de nommer un garant pour chaque
projet qui serait soumis à concertation
et de maintenir la participation
continue jusqu'à l'autorisation du
projet dont je voulais savoir quel est
votre avis par rapport à à cette à ces
travaux de modernisation de
participation du public et des
procédures environnementales faites par
le siège 2D et j'ai bien compris le fait
que vous ne retenez pas la proposition
suivante qui est celle de faire de
fondre entre guillemets les fonctions de
garant et de commissaire enquêteurs
parce que c'est aussi une des
propositions du sujet OBD merci j'ai la
parole à Monsieur gold
le président madame la Présidente
l'utilité et la pertinence du débat
public n'est plus approuvé de nombreux
sont les projets qui ont été modifiés
voir
remanier de façon significative
la réforme du dialogue environnemental a
fait évoluer les procédures de
participation du public et donc élargi
considérablement les champs des
compétences de la scène d'épée mais les
dossiers devant légalement faire l'objet
d'une saisine de la CNDP sont retenus
sur des critères quantitatifs plus que
qualitatifs en effet seuls les projets
importants en termes de coûts sont
soumis à débat or d'un point de vue éco
systémique des projets d'envergure
financière plus modestes mais concernant
des zones fragiles peuvent aussi
engendrer des impacts environnementaux
importants et étendu
de plus le contexte de réchauffement
climatique et crise énergétique nous
pousse collectivement à accélérer le
développement des énergies renouvelables
donc le projet de loi prévoit
l'accélération des procédures dans nos
circonscriptions nous constatons une
prise de conscience de l'urgence
climatique mais beaucoup de résistance
des habitants et parfois des élus face
au projet d'éoliennes de photovoltaïques
et autres méthaniseurs alors avec votre
expérience du débat public
quels sont selon vous les pistes pour
favoriser le développement des énergies
renouvelables tout en protégeant les
zones les plus fragiles bien sûr mais en
favorisant une meilleure acceptation
populaire des outils de la transition
y compris donc des petits projets qui
impactent chacun de nos départements ce
qui reprend les interrogations de
Stéphane de Milly sur l'éolien mais
aussi sur l'ensemble des outils de
production d'énergie
merci je vais donner la parole à Nicole
Bonnefoy
puis après je donnerai la parole la
présidente pour répondre aux questions
subsidiaire alors les questions
concernant le projet de loi c'est plus
exactement sur l'article 2 où je
m'interroge lorsqu'il ajoute au cas des
grammes Sion de l'enquête publique les
projets soumis a permis de permis de
démolir ou d'une déclaration préalable
lorsqu'il relève d'une évaluation
environnementale après examen au cas par
cas à ce stade rien n'interdirait de
diviser les grands projets en plusieurs
petits projets dont la puissance serait
inférieure à 1 MW pour échapper à
l'enquête publique donc que pensez-vous
de cette possible dérogation à
l'information des citoyens la deuxième
question concerne l'article 3 qui donne
clairement la possibilité d'imposer aux
élus des modifications profondes de leur
PADD les élus locaux sont des passeurs
d'information non négligeables il
contribue justement à l'acceptabilité en
permettant de prendre un exergue de
mettre en exergue les atouts et les
risques de tels infrastructures dans
votre avis vous indiquez que la réforme
envisagée ne doit pas se traduire par
une régression
droit à l'information et à la
participation du public qui est un droit
constitutionnel donc que pensez-vous
madame la présidence du risque de
dématérialisation
généralisée des enquêtes publiques au
regard des populations rurales exposées
qui sont souvent vieillissantes et un
peu encline à ne pas maîtriser l'outil
numérique donc est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un
risque de laisser sur le bord du chemin
toute une partie de la population qui
pourtant bel et bien concernée par ses
nouvelles infrastructures et la question
subsidiaire concerne notre domaine sur
lequel ici au Sénat dans cette
commission nous avons beaucoup travaillé
il s'agit de la culture de la sécurité
la culture du risque qui est un élément
indispensable pour améliorer notre
résilience face à des événements
exceptionnels comme les catastrophes
climatiques ou les accidents industriels
et donc quelles perception avez-vous de
cette culture de la sécurité chez nos
concitoyens à travers les concertations
et les débats que vous avez pu mener et
sent qu'il y a une vraie appétence
des citoyens pour ces questions de
risque et de sécurité et comment
pourrions-nous pourrait-on la renforcer
merci
madame la Présidente
monsieur le Président bon alors un bon
plat de résistance
donc
oui monsieur le sénateur
Houlgate alors merci effectivement sur
le but du débat public alors j'aurais dû
parler de ça avant il y a une grande
modification par la loi et ça qu'en 2018
sur la manière dont on devait mener les
débats publics sur les projets de de
parc éolien en mer auparavant on mené
les débats publics une fois que le parc
avait été attribué au porteur de projets
donc la zone était définie les
caractéristiques du parc étaient
définies ce qui crée énormément de
crispations avec le public qui nous
disait mais si tout est défini il y a
plus rien à débattre et notamment sur
diète Le Tréport on s'est rendu compte
qu'il aurait fallu modifier la zone pour
que elle soit beaucoup plus acceptable
notamment pour les pour les pêcheurs
donc en 2018 la loi a été modifiée et
elle a été réellement et pleinement
appliquée en Normandie ou en
Méditerranée on a sollicité la CNDP très
en amont pour identifier localement les
zones de moindre impact enfin les zones
effectivement les plus propices au
développement de parc éolien ça a été le
cas en Normandie sur la ou 5 qui est là
au 8 et ça a été le cas aussi en
Méditerranée ça n'a pas réellement été
le cas ensuite Bretagne et à Oléron ou
en réalité la zone avait déjà été
prédéfinie localement avec les acteurs
avec les acteurs locaux et on est venu
ensuite nous voir en nous disant bah
est-ce que c'est la bonne zone grosso
modo on nous a demandé de mettre un
grain de riz sur une confettis donc ça
crée quand même quelques difficultés et
avec les acteurs locaux qui nous ont dit
mais attendez on a déjà concerté
pourquoi est-ce que maintenant vous
allez reconcerter avec le public et avec
le public qui nous a dit les marges de
choix sont assez faibles ça conduit
d'ailleurs à Oléron de complètement a
complètement sorti de la zone puisque
c'était pas la bonne la bonne la bonne
zone donc ces nouvelles modalités depuis
2018 elle fonctionne plutôt bien
et voilà elle fonctionne plutôt bien et
bon ben on l'a vu on a fait un débat en
2019 on attribué maintenant donc il y a
deux zones énormes qui ont été choisies
en Normandie et qui ont été plutôt
efficaces le principe de la concertation
continue donc entre le moment du débat
public jusqu'à
l'enquête publique grosso modo ou la
ppve ce principe existe il y a bien une
concertation continue mais en fait elle
est un peu faible aujourd'hui elle est
un peu faible parce qu'il y a dans les
demandes du du public il y a deux choses
qui reviennent en permanence la première
c'est d'être associé à l'élaboration du
cahier des charges et ça on n'a jamais
eu gain de cause sur le sujet le cahier
des charges est élaboré j'allais dire en
chambre on n'a jamais eu de réelles
transparence sur la manière dont il est
élaboré et sur la prise en compte par
exemple des critères environnementaux
dans le cahier des charges le deuxième
point qui est systématiquement demandé
et qu'on recommande systématiquement
c'est qu'il y ait une instance de
concertation dédiée pour les pêcheurs
parce que vraiment il y a des questions
des problèmes spécifiques qui se plus
pour la pêche et ce qu'ils vont pouvoir
pêcher au milieu des parcs quel sera le
régime de responsabilité en cas de en
cas de difficulté et là de la même
manière on n'a jamais eu gain de cause
donc on a une concertation continue mais
qui pourrait être qui pourrait être un
peu amélioré et quand effectivement
aujourd'hui
fusionner garant et commissaire
enquêteurs comme je vous le disais on
n'a pas les mêmes missions entre une
obligation absolue de neutralité qui est
importante dans la participation parce
que c'est un peu la condition de
confiance si on commence nous à prendre
position sur les sujets si on est par
exemple si on prend une position
favorable au nucléaire vous imaginez
bien que tous les anti-nucléaires ne
vont jamais venir participer à nos à nos
débats publics alors qu'un commissaire
enquêteur on lui demande et le col lui
demande d'émettre un avis un avis motivé
donc il faudrait changer l'émission pour
que ce soit pour que ce soit possible
monsieur le sénateur gold alors vous
êtes revenu effectivement sur la
question des des critères qui font que
la saisine de la CNDP est obligatoire ou
pas ces critères c'est en réalité c'est
qu'est-ce qui a un impact sur
l'environnement ou pas aujourd'hui dans
le code de l'environnement c'est
l'article r121-12
j'ai tout entre deux et 12 mais c'est le
R121 ça c'est sûr le
r121-12 de mémoire effectivement ne fixe
que des seuils financiers ce qui est pas
toujours pertinent parce que vous pouvez
avoir des petits projets qui ont
énormément d'impact
environnemental donc pour ces plus
petits projets on peut être saisi de
manière volontaire ça c'est une
possibilité et c'est et c'est
relativement fréquent l'autre limite de
cet article c'est que sont exclus un
certain nombre de projets qui ont
réellement un impact sur l'environnement
par exemple les Data Center vous avez
des Data Center aujourd'hui à 130
mégawatts ils sont complètement exclus
de la participation du public
par exemple une extension de capacité
d'aéroport le terminal 4 à Roissy donc
qui quand même entraîné une augmentation
de capacité monumentale est exclue de la
participation obligatoire donc ADP est
venu nous voir de manière volontaire
mais il y était absolument pas obligé
donc il y a bien un problème
effectivement d'adaptation de cette
obligation de participation à la réalité
en fait des des nouveaux projets comment
favoriser les le développement des
énergies renouvelables y compris les
petits projets
sur sur le terrain le première chose que
je vous disais c'est de de mettre les
choses dans l'ordre effectivement de
voir quel est le potentiel ou est-ce
qu'on peut les mettre quels sont les
conflits d'usage donc avoir une vraie
une image un peu fidèle du territoire et
se mettent d'accord sur ces sur ces
conflits d'usage le deuxième élément
c'est que la participation telle que à
notre stade à nous comme elle est très
en amont elle va pas mesurer
l'acceptabilité parce que on met en
débat l'opportunité de faire ce projet
mais ces alternatives est-ce qu'on fait
de manière un peu bête est-ce qu'on fait
un parc éolien ou est-ce qu'on fait un
parc photovoltaïque c'est ça qu'on va
mettre en débat donc on va plutôt
identifier nous les conditions de
faisabilité du projet qu'est-ce qui
compte qu'est-ce qui vraiment fait débat
sur sur le territoire mais si on met
bien les choses dans l'ordre le zonage
bien l'identification des conditions de
de faisabilité on arrive effectivement à
mener à bien des amener à bien des des
projets sur le terrain mais en fait le
point aujourd'hui c'est que le public
parfois nous dit mais on a l'impression
que c'est anarchique quoi on ne sait pas
exactement où seront implantés les
différents projets donc le besoin de
visibilité de planification on l'a sur
le maritime comme sur le terrestre mais
on a vraiment besoin de partir du
terrain et pas l'inverse
ça c'est un autre point qu'on entend
dans tous les débats
la première réticence c'est quand les
personnes ont le sentiment que c'est un
projet national qu'on veut en plaquer
sur un territoire et l'exigence de
territorialisation des projets qu'on
peut comprendre elle se pose elle se
pose à chaque fois on l'a eu on l'a eu
sur des on l'a eu pour horizéo qui était
un projet porté par engie et néo n on
l'a eu sur un projet de parc éolien au
Blayais qui était pourtant sur le site
d'EDF donc on l'a à chaque on l'a à
chaque fois
alors madame la sénatrice vous me posez
beaucoup de colle merci
sur l'article 2 alors on nous on sait
que centrer sur les articles qui nous
concernaient directement mais on a
effectivement regardé les autres les
autres articles globalement ce qui est
assez
ce qui est assez gênant en ce moment en
termes de participation c'est toutes les
lois d'exception qui font que dans un
domaine on aurait tel procédure dans un
autre domaine on aurait été le procédure
et il y en a beaucoup ce qui ne permet
pas ni aux élus ni au public
de bénéficier d'une certaine
clarification une certaine clarté des
procédures donc on n'est pas favorable à
ces mesures d'exception qui grosso modo
laisse en plus entendre que l'enquête
publique serait
inutile ou serait une procédure
superfétatoire et ceci nous amène du
coup à la deuxième question sur le
risque de dématérialisation le risque de
dématérialisation c'est le développement
aujourd'hui des procédures de
participation par voie électronique les
ppve il y a des ppve avec garant ou sans
garant il y a des ppve généralement
c'est sans garants mais vous avez des
ppve avec garant par exemple sur les
projets olympiques par exemple sur les
prisons aussi donc le garant est là pour
vérifier que la procédure se déroule de
manière sincère il rédige entre
guillemets les conclusions de la
procédure c'est-à-dire il fait le bilan
de ce que le public a dit et en plus
j'avoue qu'on demande nous au garant de
faire en sorte que la procédure ne soit
pas que numérique il y a 14% de la
population qui n'a pas accès au
numérique 14% sur l'ensemble du
territoire donc si on fait des ppve on
exclut de fait cette population qui
souvent effectivement est une population
rurale ou qui n'est pas familière avec
avec le numérique le deuxième élément on
a eu à faire par exemple les ppve sur
les infrastructures liées aux Jeux
olympiques en Seine-Saint-Denis et là on
leur a dit mais on sait une Saint-Denis
si vous faites que des PPE vous êtes sûr
que la plupart des personnes ne seront
ni informés de l'existence de ce projet
ni ne pourrons participer donc on a
exigé qui est des procédures en
présentiel aussi parce que la
participation 100% numérique va de fait
s'exclure et donc ça ne répond pas à ce
qui est inscrit dans la Constitution et
dans le code de l'environnement qui est
que toute personne doit avoir la
possibilité de d'être informé et de et
de participer donc ça c'est sur la dém
la réalisation et en ce sens d'ailleurs
on porte le même discours avec la
Défenseur des droits qui dit dans un
autre domaine mais c'est aussi un
exercice d'un droit à la participation
qui dit
qui dit la même chose et dans nos
procédures nous-même pendant le covid on
a refusé on n'a jamais fait de
concertation ou de débats publics qui
soient uniquement numérique même pendant
le covid on s'est débrouillé pour qu'il
y ait des moments en présentiel parce
que sinon c'est de la fausse
participation ou c'est de la
participation détournée enfin sur la
culture de la sécurité et du risque
alors ce sujet là nous on le voit
apparaître plus ou moins en fonction des
projets qui sont mis en débat
sur le nucléaire quand on a organisé le
débat sur le plan national de gestion
des matières et déchirées radioactifs le
pnjmdr bien connu évidemment le question
la question est souvent venue sur la
table pour le futur débat sur les EPR 2
évidemment ça va venir aussi sur
ça va être d'être accessible à tout le
monde ça va être d'avoir que ça va être
que l'information soit lisible et
compréhensible par toutes et tous l'IRSN
nous a remis hier soir deux expertises
je vous invite vraiment à les lire elles
sont vraiment formidables sur le bilan
des EPR d'une part et d'autre part donc
c'est en complémentaire à la mission qui
avait été menée par Jean-Marie folle sur
le sujet mais d'autre part quels sont
les alternatives à LEPR dans le monde y
compris les SMS c'est des sujets qui
sont passionnants qui sont engagés pour
l'avenir maintenant on a dit à l'IRSN ce
serait quand même important que au-delà
du document qui est passionnant vous
puissiez faire des vidéos ou des
éléments explicatifs accessibles aux
grand public parce que ce sont des
sujets majeurs une fois qu'on a les
explications ça se comprend très très
bien
mais il faut que ce soit accessible au
grand public
sur ou pardon Stéphane je suis désolé
excuse-moi
excuse-moi comme ça le meilleur pour la
fin monsieur le sénateur
désolé
sur les effectivement
sur la concertation avec les élus locaux
on dit souvent et on le répète et je
sais que aujourd'hui tout n'est que
accélération et
urgence mais on répète tout le temps que
pour que la participation est du sens et
pour que la concertation ait du sens il
faut lui laisser le temps il faut déjà
laisser le temps à l'ensemble des
acteurs et au public de s'informer d'une
part et ensuite il faut laisser le temps
aux arguments de se rencontrer de
s'échanger que les uns et les autres
comprennent les arguments de l'autre le
pourquoi il a tel ou telle position ce
qui fait potentiellement d'ailleurs
évoluer les arguments des uns et des
autres donc le temps de la concertation
et de la participation en général est un
temps important et c'est pas un temps
perdu l'argument souvent de
l'accélération du temps de la
participation qui prendrait trop de
temps
ce qui n'est d'ailleurs prouvé par aucun
des rapports aucun ont été commandées
sur sur ce sujet est un argument que je
trouve assez dangereux parce que il
laisserait à penser que le temps de la
démocratie qu'elle soit participative ou
représentative est un temps est un temps
trop long et un temps perdu
effectivement or c'est le temps où on va
identifier les conditions de réalisation
du du projet et ce qu'on montrait
d'ailleurs les rapports c'est que
c'est que les délais qu'on observe sur
les grands projets sont généralement
liés au délai d'arbitrage d'arbitrage
politique et au délai de financement en
général et ça c'est dans les les
différents rapports récents c'est
extrêmement bien documenté y compris le
rapport d'ailleurs Guyot qui était un
rapport d'un industriel donc on peut pas
taxer d'être nécessairement favorable
aux uns ou aux autres qui a exactement
la même la même conclusion donc notre
position c'est qu'effectivement la vie
des populations et des élus locaux et on
met pas les uns en face des autres en
général au contraire l'essentiel c'est
que les parties prenantes se rencontrent
et absolument nécessaire pour éviter de
commettre des erreurs on a fait on doit
être à 105 ou 106 débats publics donc
les débats publics c'est ce qu'on fait
sur les plus gros projets
vraiment les plus gros projets ou les
plus les plus conflictuels on a regardé
depuis 25 ans combien de projets étaient
aujourd'hui sortis de terre
moins de 20
moins de 20 sont sortis de terre
donc il y a un réel enjeu effectivement
à remettre à plat l'ensemble des
procédures mais il me semble pas au
regard de ces chiffres que la question
soit le temps de la de la participation
en général quand au délai de
consultation sur ce projet de loi en
particulier
vous avez vu les réactions du Conseil
national de la transition qui s'est
exprimée à plusieurs à plusieurs
occasions
nous typiquement on s'est prononcé avec
ce que l'on avait sur la table mais on
est encore en train d'essayer de
d'organiser des réunions avec la dgmr
alors qui a changé de nom
c'est des géants quoi ils ont changé de
nom et la dège pour voir concrètement
comment on met à plat leur proposition
sur sur l'article 12 donc oui s'agissant
de ce texte on comprend bien l'objectif
mais il y a deux éléments dans ce texte
il y a les mesures temporaires et puis
il y a les mesures permanentes peut-être
que les mesures permanentes auraient pu
être discutées là je dépasse mon rôle je
suis désolé mais elles auraient
peut-être pu être discutées dans le
cadre de la loi programmation énergie
climat
après la concertation nationale qui
aurait pu mettre à plat l'ensemble de
ces sujets
pardon
alors comme je vous le disais nous on
est tellement en amont que on en est pas
encore à ce à ce stade là nous on
identifier les conditions de faisabilité
on n'est pas encore au stade où le
projet est en voie d'être autorisé juste
après donc on est on n'est jamais
confronté en réalité à cette
à cette difficulté parce que
ça n'est qu'à l'issue d'un débat public
ou d'une concertation préalable que le
décideur pourra dire s'il poursuit ou
pas son projet et ça n'est qu'à l'issue
de cette procédure qui pourra déposer sa
première demande d'autorisation donc on
en est vraiment pas au stade de
l'opposabilité là c'est encore un autre
sujet maintenant évidemment tout ce qui
est propice à la participation du public
d'une manière ou d'une autre à sa
participation à l'élaboration des
décisions on est favorable mais je
dépasserai mon rôle si je vous répondais
merci que j'ai encore cinq collègues et
nous devons libérer la salle pour 10h20
pas libérer là ça nous recevons monsieur
Berville à 10h15
alors il se dit que nous aurions la
meilleure démocratie et envie de mentale
qui puisse se faire est-ce que il vous
semble parce que vous avez mentionné des
petites régressions récentes que notre
démocratie environnementale s'abîme un
petit peu et puis maintenant je vais
vous demander puisque il y a très
concrètement un changement de paradigme
dans notre pays puisque tous ces
dispositifs ont été pensés pour des
projets qui étaient souvent des projets
importants au niveau financement puisque
vous avez dit que la saisie ne peut se
faire que au dessus de 300 millions
d'euros or ce qui est en train de se
passer sur le territoire c'est quelque
chose de complètement différent puisque
par exemple dans mon département le lot
pour les projets photovoltaïques c'est
plein de petits projets qui se montent
sur les territoires parfois dans des
communes qui sont très proches les unes
des autres et donc se pose peut-être la
question mais vous me direz ce que vous
en pensez de cette consultation qui
pourrait se faire parce que on voit ces
petits projets donc émergé de partout et
qui vont avoir certainement un impact
environnemental globalement alors que
sont des projets privés que forcément
ils ne vont pas recourir de manière
volontaire comme vous l'avez signalé
pour demander ses enquêtes ou c'est
consultations du public et que peut-être
ce serait nécessaire et peut-être
pourquoi pas envisager quand on a alors
il faudrait peut-être mettre des
critères peut-être vous en avez en tête
qui permettrait d'avoir ces
consultations du public sur pourquoi pas
un département si on voit que plein de
projets émergent et qui de toute façon
ne provoquerait pas cette consultation
du public qui serait pourtant nécessaire
puisqu'ils vont avoir des impacts sur
l'environnement et pour ce qui concerne
du mix énergétique effectivement
comme précédemment quand tout le
nucléaire a été installé sur nos
territoires il n'y a pas eu de
consultation du public est-ce qu'il ne
faudrait pas effectivement alors il y en
a une qui est lancée mais est-ce qu'elle
le correspond tout à fait à ce qui
serait l'interrogation qu'on ferait aux
Français sur le choix qu'ils ont par
rapport à leur futur énergétique ce qui
est un choix évidemment extrêmement
important pour pour nous tous dans le
pays madame
si madame la Présidente je souhaitais
vous dire que je partageais votre
inquiétude et l'inquiétude de ma
collègue Nicole Bonnefoy par rapport à
l'extension de la consultation
électronique qui exclut de chez comme
vous l'avez dit 14 millions de personnes
considérées comme
exclus de l'électronisme mais également
50% de la population qui n'est 14% chez
des Louis XIV
14% de la population je suis troublée et
50% qui se sont mal à l'aise par rapport
au numérique et donc on peut dire que
vraiment cette ce mode de consultation
est complètement dissuasif et
contre-productif par rapport à
l'objectif qui est le nôtre à savoir
qu'il y a un maximum de personnes qui
participent et s'approprie le projet et
dans le même ordre d'idée je voulais
évoquer la remise en question du rôle
social du commissaire enquêteur dans
l'article 2 du projet de loi qui nous
est soumis le commissaire enquêteur a me
semble-t-il un rôle important puisqu'il
reformule aide à la compréhension de
chacun des projets qui sont parfois très
complexes du point de vue technique et
mettre en jeu beaucoup de de données et
puis ensuite il aide aussi un certain
nombre de citoyens à formuler des avis
et donc son rôle est majeur et je
voulais vous lui demander qu'est-ce que
ce que vous pensiez justement de cette
remise en question du commissaire
enquêteur et moi je voulais faire le
constat général qu'on veut aller vite
mais qu'on n'est pas garanti d'aller
vraiment bien dans le bon sens avec ces
deux éléments en tout cas
merci je vais donner la parole à Madame
Saint-Pée
si monsieur le Président merci madame la
Présidente et Madame la pièce présidente
pour votre présence devant nous ce matin
alors vous avez rapidement évoqué dans
vos propos liminaires madame la
Présidente un questionnement que je
voudrais vous poser plus précisément
concernant l'article 13 du projet de loi
qui prévoit la possibilité de mutualiser
les débats pour l'éolien en mer alors
très concrètement madame la Présidente
il voyait vous une manière d'enrichir le
débat public ou au contraire il voyait
vous une menace merci
parole est à Monsieur Pascal Martin
merci Monsieur prudent madame la
Présidente la scène des pères et ses a
récemment été mobilisé vous y avez fait
allusion tout à l'heure pour la
concertation autour du nouveau plan de
gestion des matières et déchets
radioactifs et le sera pour le débat sur
le nouveau programme du nucléaire
français d'ailleurs la presse a publié
l'avant-projet de loi du gouvernement
sur le nouveau nucléaire pouvez-vous
nous en dire plus sur la méthode les
modalités le calendrier de ce débat
structurant et déterminant pour notre
politique énergétique quels sont les
principes qui doivent guider selon vous
cette concertation enfin quels seront
les lieux de débat et de concertation
merci merci chers collègues à parole est
à Guillaume chevrolier
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente vous l'avez dit à
complémentarité entre le débat
participatif et la démocratie
représentative on voit chaque jour dans
nos collectivités les élus locaux
organisent des concertations pour mener
à bien des projets donc ça ça prend du
temps et vous l'avez dit également il
faut prendre le temps de la discussion
et là on est sur un projet loi
d'accélération du déploiement des
énergies renouvelables donc c'est cette
conciliation et la gestion des
contradictions qu'il faut il faut
trouver la ligne de crête moi je voulais
vous interroger sur ça a été évoqué
également sur les consultations
par les moyens numériques aujourd'hui
par voie électronique la place de du
numérique du cyber pour les
consultations quelle est la aujourd'hui
dans les consultations que vous opérez
et ce qu'il y a des comme pour tout le
monde des attaques cyber est-ce que vous
en avez recensé est-ce qu'elles viennent
du National et parfois de
l'international on est sur des sujets de
déploiement des renouvelables avec des
en stratégique pour pour le pays donc on
peut s'attendre à avoir des des actions
de puissance extérieure quel niveau de
protection pour mener à bien le débat
public sécurisé sur le plan numérique
dans le projet de loi il est fait état
de l'acceptabilité du partage de la
valeur locale est-ce que vous dans les
consultations que vous avez amené ce
point de la le partage de la valeur
locale est un point déterminant qui
prime par rapport à des considérations
environnementales ou est-ce que vous
avez déjà une analyse un recul pour
hiérarchiser un petit peu les points qui
sont importants pour la population pour
l'acceptabilité justement merci
je vais donner la parole à Ronan dans
tech et puis à la présidente pour
réponse merci monsieur le président
madame la Présidente les projets dont on
parle sont des projets pour pour
plusieurs décennies et dans plusieurs
décennies le temps aura sérieusement
changé c'est à dire que sur ces projets
il serait bien d'avoir un volet lié à
l'adaptation au changement climatique
donc ma question va être assez simple
pour savoir si aujourd'hui la CNDP à la
capacité d'intégrer la question de
l'adaptation et l'évolution du climat
dans les concertations est-ce que vous
avez les données est-ce que vous avez un
cadre y compris fourni par l'État sur un
terme un peu prospective parce que cette
question de l'adaptation alors ça
dépasse les énergies renouvelables mais
les énergies ronales étant très liées
autant qu'il fait par définition elles
sont particulièrement concernées donc
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui cette question
d'intégrer l'adaptation au changement
climatique dans les concertations vous
la voyez
c'est mature ou là on a des marges de
progrès
merci avant que je donne la parole à la
Présidente il y a d'autres demandes de
parole bon ben
même la présence vous avez un peu moins
de 15 minutes pour répondre
merci monsieur le Président en plus j'ai
pas répondu à votre question sur les
moyens alors je suis quand même pas doué
parce que normalement un président
d'institution c'est la première question
à laquelle il répond mais
madame la sénatrice m'a imprévise
sur la démocratie environnementale
effectivement on a un modèle qui est
très abouti dans le cadre du du code de
l'environnement est-ce qu'elle s'abîme
il y a eu des régressions effectivement
je les ai listés je les ai listés tout à
l'heure dont une importante qui est
celle du droit d'initiative et j'y
reviendrai parce que ça rejoint votre
votre deuxième votre deuxième question
et pour autant sur le terrain il y a
quand même comme je vous le disais bah
nous on a de plus en plus de demandes on
a fait on vient nous voir pour tout y
compris les concertations sur le
numérique responsable à 5G enfin voilà
il y a une vraie il y a une demande très
très profonde comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure en introduction on a un
déploiement de pratique très important
dans des petites communes et c'était pas
habituel parce que ça demande des moyens
donc c'était plutôt habituellement les
grandes communes les grandes
intercommunalités qui développaient ce
type de participation en tout cas on a
une démocratie qui est bien vivante et
qui est assez riche sur le sur le
terrain et puis qui surtout au tour le
coup à cette idée qu'on ne lit
d'ailleurs souvent que dans les livres
où il y aurait d'un côté la démocratie
représentative et de l'autre côté la
démocratie participative les élus de
terrain alors on le sait mieux au Sénat
ailleurs puisque en général c'est plutôt
des élus de terrain que au contraire les
deux s'alimentent et en général ça
fonctionne plutôt ça fonctionne plutôt
bien
sur les saisines obligatoires ou pas
donc oui il y a la possibilité de nous
saisir de manière volontaire
l'incitation à le faire a été d'autant
moins importante maintenant que le droit
d'initiative est presque impossible à
exercer tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que le droit d'initiative
aujourd'hui on peut des acteurs qui
seraient
qui considérait qu'un projet qu'un
impact sur l'environnement devrait être
soumis à participation aujourd'hui pour
nous saisir ils n'ont que deux mois pour
le faire ce qui est très court parce
qu'en général la publicité de ces
projets elle est faite sur des sites
c'est difficile d'avoir connaissance
d'avoir connaissance du projet donc le
délai de moi il passe très très vite et
ça ça n'incite pas du tout et ça n'est
pas favorable du tout à la participation
à la participation du public
s'agissant du ah oui s'agissant du
nucléaire donc le nucléaire alors il y a
eu on a fait plusieurs débats sur des
projets sur des projets nucléaires le
premier c'était en 2004 c'était on a
fait 7 débats et c'était sur des projets
de
[Musique]
ans
le premier c'était en 2004 sur le projet
d'enrichissement de d'une usine
d'enrichissement duranium donc on en a
fait plusieurs maintenant effectivement
la politique générale et la place du
nucléaire dans le mix énergétique n'a
pas été mis en débat puisque quand on a
fait le débat public sur la PPE en 2018
le gouvernement en fait nous a dit non
le c'est pas dans le débat c'est en
dehors du en dehors du du débat de toute
façon ça va arriver dans le débat que ce
soit le débat public ou le débat
parlementaire puisque on a un plafond en
termes de gigawatt sur la puissance
nucléaire qui est fixée dans la loi si
on construit de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires il faudra faire évoluer ce
plafond donc le débat il va être sur la
place publique très
très prochainement d'une manière ou de
d'une manière ou d'une autre et je vais
revenir tout à l'heure sur la question
de l'organisation du débat sur les sur
les EPR
donc madame la sénatrice filleul vous
nous avez effectivement fait part de vos
inquiétudes sur le numérique
effectivement je on les partage puisque
comme on l'indique on ne peut pas tout
faire par le par le numérique et surtout
en fait
on voit que ça ne fonctionne pas puisque
ça exclut une grande partie de des
personnes sur notre relation les rôles
des commissaires enquêteurs en fait nous
on travaille beaucoup avec les
commissaires enquêteurs il y a
d'ailleurs il y a des commissaires
enquêteurs qui sont aussi garants de la
de la CNDP normalement pas sur les mêmes
projets puisque
évidemment on peut pas être neutre et
puis après et mettre un avis nous notre
travail c'est de dire il faut une
continuité il faut un continuum on a une
participation préalable qui dit beaucoup
de choses c'est important après que ce
serait important qu'on travaille qu'on
mette en place une réunion commune
contient un passage du relais entre un
garant sur un projet et un commissaire
enquêteur pour faire le point sur ce qui
s'est dit sur le sur le sur le projet et
puis partagez un petit peu nos méthodes
parce que les commissaires enquêteurs
peuvent aussi aller plus loin dans ce
qu'ils font dans ce qu'ils font et aller
plus loin dans leur interprétation de la
de la loi pour organiser des réunions
par exemple donc oui on est on travaille
très très bien ensemble et on considère
que c'est un continuum voilà de
participation qui va du débat sur
l'opportunité au débat sur
l'autorisation de lancer les le travaux
grosso modo et
s'agissant de de du délai de la de la
question de l'urgence quand vous disiez
tout aujourd'hui on veut tout le temps
aller vite la question effectivement est
de savoir si on veut aller vite ou si on
veut aller loin
et souvent en karaté je faisais du
karaté quand j'étais jeune
toujours il faut pas confondre vitesse
et précipitation
sur
madame la sénatrice
c'est un pays sur la mutualisation des
débats sur les essentiellement les
projets de parc éolien en mer et les DSF
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
c'est un on est très favorable à ce que
dans le cadre des DSF il y a
effectivement une vision claire de ce
que l'on souhaite faire en termes de
développement des énergies renouvelables
sur sur la façade
et qu'on est d'ailleurs sur une échelle
de temps qui soit pas que 6 ans le temps
des DSF est un peu trop court alors 6
ans c'est l'obligation européenne en
fait parce qu'il faut rendre compte tous
les 6 ans de ce qui a été mis en oeuvre
dans le cadre des DSF mais pourquoi pas
faire des DSF de 12 ans avec une clause
de revoyure tous les 6 ans effectivement
pour donner un peu de visibilité parce
que pour un industriel une échelle de 6
ans c'est une échelle qui n'a pas
beaucoup de de sens pour développer ses
parcs ces parc éoliens en mer donc
effectivement on est favorable à ça mais
on pense que il y a quand même deux
temps il y a un temps résoudre les
conflits les conflits d'usage en tout
cas d'occupation de l'espace et ensuite
un temps pour débattre de du
développement des parcs éoliens en mer
et où on les situe et à quel à quel
échéance
monsieur le sénateur ah oui parce
qu'elle Martin sur comment va
s'organiser le débat public sur le
programme nouveau nucléaire et en
particulier le PR2 de Pony donc il
s'ouvre le 27 octobre
il s'ouvre le 27 octobre en fin de
journée
à Dieppe et à Paris la première question
qu'on va mettre en débat d'ailleurs le
27 octobre c'est à quoi sert ce débat
puisque
puisque souvent nos concitoyens nous
disent mais après tout le président de
la République a fait des déclarations
les fameux discours de Besançon
il y a un projet de loi d'accélération
du nucléaire donc tout est décidé donc
c'est pour c'est pour ça qu'on pose la
question de manière un peu brutale
d'abord il va servir à informer la
population c'est quand même important
c'est
et surtout il va servir parce que il va
alimenter un débat le vrai décideur
aujourd'hui ça va être le Parlement en
fait c'est quand même une échéance
énorme la loi de programmation énergique
climat donc le vrai décideur c'est le
Parlement donc ce débat il va servir
parce qu'en fait aujourd'hui rien n'est
décidé et que tout sera décidé au
Parlement pendant l'année 2023
effectivement je doute que ce soit voté
en juillet en juillet 2023 ça semble
difficile donc le débat public a été
séquencé en plusieurs questions il a il
y a 10 questions
il va avoir lieu sur l'ensemble du
territoire national évidemment plus de
réunions en Normandie puisque c'est le
premier territoire concerné mais il y
aura aussi des réunions à Saclay il y
aura aussi des réunions
alors au Tréport oui à Lille à Lyon à
Tours parce que en fait on va pas
simplement mettre en débat la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs mais
tout ce que ça implique qu'est-ce que ça
implique en amont et ce qu'il faut de
nouvelles
usines d'enrichissement d'uranium
comment est-ce qu'on va s'approvisionner
qu'est-ce que ça implique en aval et ce
qu'il faut une nouvelle piscine encore
une une troisième une piscine à la Hague
et ce qu'il faut est-ce que les
capacités de cigéos sont adaptés donc on
doit effectivement dérouler l'ensemble
de la chaîne mais surtout on met pas en
débat que panli on met aussi en débat
les deux autres paires de réacteurs qui
sont qui sont envisagées les moyens de
participer sont extrêmement variés il y
a bien évidemment les réunions publiques
il y a des ateliers spécifiques en
fonction de certaines thématiques il y a
une plateforme participative
tu auras probablement dès la possibilité
d'audo organiser des réunions locales
parce que on veut que le débat soit très
démultiplié sur l'ensemble du territoire
il y a et c'est en cours ce qu'on
appelle une clarification des
controverses il y a certains points de
controverse extrêmement important qui
donc on identifie déjà les points qui
font des accords et on demande aux
experts ceux qui sont pour ceux qui sont
contre sur ces pointes des accords
d'expliquer le pourquoi et on permet
comme ça ça permet de confronter leurs
arguments et de les rendre complément
compréhensible
à tout le monde et puis bien évidemment
il y a une mobilisation des écoles et
des universités pour que
ce débat soit aussi pris en charge et
préemptée par par les jeunes puis il y
aura j'imagine des passerelles avec
votre assemblée des votre assemblée des
jeunesse donc 27 octobre 27 février
c'est une durée légale 4 mois on s'est
fixé par le code de l'environnement et
le président du Bd bas c'est Michel
Badré ça a été le premier président de
l'autorité environnementale et qui a une
qualité incroyable c'est qu'il est
capable de mettre autour des Latins
bleus les pour et les contre il est
reconnu des deux il est reconnu par les
par les deux parties
oui je pense que j'ai à peu près tout
dit sur sur ce débat enfin pas tout ce
sera bien plus riche que ce que je vous
ai dit monsieur le sénateur
chevrolier sur
l'accélération des du développement des
énergies des énergies renouvelables
effectivement quand on lit de toute
façon quand on sait le
l'enjeu que constitue le fameux mur de
2050 c'est à dire électrification des
usages
fin de vie de la plupart des réacteurs
nucléaires donc tous les ça constitue
quelque chose d'énorme l'échéance 2050
est effectivement un mur dont on n'a pas
encore idée donc l'accélération de
développement des énergies des carbonées
en général et est une évidence en tout
cas c'est une évidence technique
simplement dans ce texte de loi il y a
effectivement deux éléments il y a des
mesures temporaires d'accélération
temporaire et puis il y a des mesures de
plus de plus long terme et ce qui peut
poser question c'est finalement pourquoi
est-ce que ces mesures de plus long
terme pour faciliter le déploiement des
énergies renouvelables ne sont pas
intégrés dans le futur loi de
programmation énergie climat ne sont pas
une des composantes de cette de cette
loi ce qui vous laisserait d'ailleurs
plus de temps pour pouvoir en débattre
mais c'est une question beaucoup plus
politique qu'une question qui intéresse
directement la scène des P donc j'arrête
là sur la place du numérique et surtout
la question des cybers des
cyber-attaques alors c'est des sujets
très très sensibles surtout quand on
parle évidemment de de nucléaire c'est
un sujet
auquel on est régulièrement confronté
nous on a maintenu alors on a une
plateforme participative qui a plusieurs
missions la première c'est de permettre
à tout le monde de poser une question et
d'obliger mettre d'ouvrage à y répondre
dans les 15 jours c'est un principe de
déposer des contributions de déposer des
éléments d'information on a maintenu une
règle qui n'est pas commune dans le
domaine du numérique qui est ce qu'on
appelle la modération a priori c'est à
dire que on ne peut être posté sur cette
plateforme et sur notre site que des
éléments qui ont été vus préalablement
et qui ont été validés pourquoi bah pour
éviter les attaques personnelles pour
éviter les dérapages pour éviter aussi
que soit mis en ligne des documents qui
pourraient être classés secret défense
ça pourrait arriver dans certains
domaines donc on a on a cette exigence
un peu stricte qui fait que aujourd'hui
alors ça arrive qu'il y ait des
tentatives en moins pour nous troller
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas été
confronté à cette à cette difficulté et
on a on m'a demandé lors du
renouvellement de la plateforme on a eu
de grands débats pour savoir si
finalement vous n'êtes pas comme tout le
monde c'est-à-dire la modération a
postériori et on a maintenu cette cette
règle parce qu'on souhaite que les
débats publics soient effectivement ne
soit pas l'objet dans lesquive
personnelle ou de dérapage des détours
par rapport à la par rapport à la loi
sur la question de la part du partage de
la valeur locale
une question qui passionne ma voisine je
vais tout de suite lui passer la parole
non merci c'est une question cruciale
qui revient systématiquement dans nos
débats vous nous avez posé la question
si c'était un sujet qui revient dans nos
débats et bien de manière dans le fait
de donner de la valeur locale et de
partager la valeur avec le local donné
de la valeur c'est la reconnaissance la
particularité des lieux dans leur
géographie physique mais pas que la
question patrimoniale paysagère encore
une fois mais pas que et partager la
valeur en des sujets qui revient souvent
dans nos débats par exemple sur l'éolien
c'est mais qui va bénéficier des profits
et des retombés au delà des avantages
fiscaux et voyez ça il y a plein de
solutions aussi concrètes la question de
l'emploi de l'emploi local revient aussi
systématiquement tout le temps il
faudrait peut-être adopter aussi des
approches qui sont non seulement
permettent de faire exprimer le local
mais de l'écouter de l'intégrer
concrètement par la suite je vous donne
un exemple très simple nous avons fait
les débats sur la politique agricole
nous avons son allé voir beaucoup
d'agriculteurs et je me souviens encore
un dans une ferme d'agriculteur il avait
une BAL dans une éolienne terrestre qui
est l'agriculteur n'indiquait pas
comment le fait d'habitude avec le
numéro qui indique la séquence de
l'implantation c'était la pâle Robert et
il disait ben quand elle quand il a en
dysfonctionnement j'appelle les
techniciens je son portable parce que
c'est mon neveu vous voyez donc avoir
des retombées locales c'est construire
vraiment à insérer localement les
projets et la prise en compte de la
question de l'emploi et savoir un peu là
voilà la rendre concrète les données de
réponse est très importante donc donner
de la valeur à partager la valeur on va
dire c'est les deux messages clés qui
nous ressortent systématiquement du
terrain et là par exemple la question de
l'intégration des pêcheurs si on parle
d'éolien offshore et une question
cruciale qu'on doit aborder pour les
intégrer effectivement une nombreux de
nos débats mais un exergue le fait que
il demande des instances dédiées
spécifiques certes beaucoup d'instance
existent mais un travail fin direct et
continue avec les pêcheurs et par
exemple le primordial
juste pour terminer donc de points
monsieur le sénateur Ronan Dantec sur la
question de l'adaptation dans nos débats
non on manque d'informations on manque
de données il y a pas mal de
cartographies qui ont été faites par
Météo France par le berger par mais
vraiment en manque de données et
aujourd'hui une des clés d'entrée qu'on
essaye maintenant de systématiser c'est
d'abord mettre en débat effectivement
l'opportunité du projet au regard des
éléments qu'on a sur sur l'adaptation
mais c'est c'est un sujet qui est trop
peu abordé trop peu abordé pardon on va
l'aborder très prochainement puisque le
prochain débat public qu'on va ouvrir
c'est un débat public sur l'eau en
Île-de-France
avec le sédif qui va toucher la qualité
de l'eau mais qui bien évidemment va
aussi mettre en débat la quantité et
l'aspect potentiel conflit d'usage même
si en Île-de-France ça se pose de
manière un petit peu différente enfin
pour les moyens monsieur le Président
parce que bon faut parler des moyens
alors la CNDP c'est une toute petite
structure c'est à dire qu'il y a 13
personnes dans l'équipe centrale et elle
repose sur un réseau de collaborateurs
occasionnels du service public de 225
230 personnes qui sont sur l'ensemble du
territoire national donc c'est des
personnes qui sont indemnisées à la
mission on leur confie une mission un
peu comme le commissaire enquêteur sauf
que c'est nous là qui les indemnisons
directement
ça ça donne c'est un énorme avantage
c'est que on est une structure
extrêmement souple extrêmement agile
extrêmement rapide dans son mode de
fonctionnement maintenant au regard de
150 procédures de concertation et débat
public sur le terrain 13 effectivement
en centrale c'est très peu on nous a
d'ailleurs supprimé un poste il y a deux
ans sans concertation sans qu'on sache
trop pourquoi je on demande pas grand
chose mais si on a deux ou trois poses
supplémentaires on sera ravis donc vous
voyez on est petit et on est modeste
merci mais merci pour ce pour cet
échange et sur les moyens si on peut
vous aider à travers des amendements le
rapporteur ne manquera pas de
vous aider
merci on va recevoir le ministre
Verville